он і був це їм нічим народом ти скіфи
кочові вершинки
чималої пасивності або the passive
посудини зал і шила зад з заклав його
латинський скарб золоту дорога тіні в
бронь атаку що в не по судан і знайшли
археологи в них могилах у криму скіфи
був і вдячним і воїном і
equis творив і свою державу дві з
половиною тисячі руки в тому напильник
при чорному морі
кримські скорботи нині демонструються
амстердамі
дістав і предметом конфлікту між Україною
це не легітимна кримська влада за
інтеграл метт повз нього проблему
зіпсованими експонатами юристи нині
виручку чоловіка по праву на лежати і
куму мати буде повернути і ФСБ
одягаємося підвищить буде знайдено
червона троянда laswell і приватний
жерці походи бельчат 6 на експонатів c
кримсько-татарський палат з музей біля
бахчисарає будинок прання будинку вин на де слова
без тіні археологічні об'єкти
заважає
своїм культурним над лазнями
яка зараз Європі виставка відриває
нині в Європі наявність 1442 музейних
предмети і поза сумами не вам на я з
крові предметів нашого архі логічного
фонду
логічного фонду алайкума
артефакти музеям криму анексованого
росію в Україні в бутіках різнина
б'ються на позицію кримської влади
українському міністерстві культури можуть
побачити давати оскар би де після
закінчення виставки
у листі завершення виставкою диску з
ситуацію ще сталося
експонати майк повернутий осі у даному
випад шматку лише за все-таки його
для того спить та розвиток україни топити
з посади рішенням ЮНЕСКО
під наглядом юнеско до лаки амстердам
раб там upon та вся у центрі конфлікту
ведмедик і вам-то сімферополем правнуки в
нідерландах ламають голову над ним кому з
літві датою скорботи результату вікон та травня
вікна zipwith вуки в амстердамського музею
виду не ті з у парочки в лосів зате про
тип a war мене relic виду криму
приблизно по риму фоліанту
виставка травня велику культурно циніст
будь ласка поверніть то борошно мовано
накласти на і російською заміський com
червона та проросійські цитати
у темно та виду миші об'єкт виставці
золота і скіфський шелом я експонатом з
київського музею
тут виставковому музеї зберігається касти
на золото скіфів
директор кати нею 100 нових хоч і розумі
з turbo вані сколах про бахчисарай
олексій штоку поважаючи кримську реліквії
українську владою вивозилося як
складу в частині державного музейного
фонду України і там викрадення повинно бути
повернено самого україну всю позицію щодо
ділять багато людей у ​​ківі і обожнюю ще
шкіряні експонати до [ __ ] знайдені в
україні та кожен елемент виставки з vin
повернувся на території України можна
його в роті поговорити з людьми про
нідерландах
тому що Європа за раз на нашому боті
і можна його надати організувати ще ви
не приїхали сюди в київ київ у раз киш
нам про бахчисарайський у палаті здається
що супу річка рахунку криму весь далеко
але для оксани а у пашки ну і ціл
шуби 100 грам a call його на вигляд давала
скорботи на виставку в Європі конфлікту на
в колу криму члени і снувала дпрв вона
боїться що ніколи на метеликів свої
найкраще експонати
Цю ціну нюху повернеться в
крим до нашого заповідника
cl та чесно трагедія завтра щось для криму
у тілах і я що
крим buff місцям sp у підставі різьблених
народів that are gray kef римлян пісні
стану
через пиво straw пролягав та давній
торгували шлях та hd китаю за багатство
ви на очах диких землі та різьблених
культур нині шмона поттер по я через
конфлікт ніжними